Hey, I'm Sami Kriegstein.
I live in Venice, California and I'm 27.
And I'm very busy.
I'm a producer.
I'm producing a feature-length documentary film.
I am a voice-over artist.
I run a film festival for music videos.
And I consult for YouTube and Web companies.
Probably the one thing that is consistent across everything that I do is my cell phone.
I have to have it with me at all times.
It's a part of my body.
I guess in that sense, it's kind of like a child...
...like, I have to know where it is and I need to make sure it's charged,...
...like, I wanted to make sure I fed it or something.
It's like my little baby.
I love going on Instagram and just hitting the "Explore" button,...
...especially really late at night.
Seeing photos from different countries...
...and you know, people from worlds that I have no concept of...
...and kind of getting to dive deep into those,...
...that kind of inspires me and helps me stay creative I think.